el escritor leyó
hola qué tal es un gran placer estar hoy
con ustedes en la represa cibernética
leonora chapman rufo valencia leonardo
jiménez y me está poniendo guineo y
pablo gómez barrios les presentamos el
castor cibernético de este fin de semana
y en vivo y en directo este viernes por
facebook live youtube y en nuestro sitio
rcn punto ce también podrán escuchar en
nuestro sitio la versión con la música
agregada que estará esta semana a cargo
del grupo arcade fire un caluroso saludo
a todas y todos y gracias por su
agradable compañía
leonora russo leonardo bienvenidos
igualmente es gracias
por acá en plena semana de olímpicos en
plena semana de olímpicos y además este
viernes es el año del nuevo año lunar
entonces parados están festejando
gracián o sea los que se rigen por el
calendario lunar que están festejando
pero los chinos ellos artículos
particularmente y le dicen adiós al año
viejo que era el año del perro y le dan
la bienvenida al no al callo
el perro que comienza a llegar el perro
exacto pasamos del gallo al perro y
entonces pues les deseamos un feliz año
nuevo a todos escuchando allá en china
porque a lo mejor en china hay
comunidades chinas en toda américa
latina y ahí hay gente que no
necesariamente es de origen chino sin
embargo festeja en el año lunar exacto y
si conoces sabes porque lo del año chino
al parecer fue que
dice la leyenda que los hombres no
tenían noción del tiempo y recurrieron
al emperador celestial para que los
ayudara y les organizará el tiempo
entonces el emperador le dijo que iba a
organizar una carrera de animales para
que y los doce primeros que llegara al
hombre participaban el órgano estaba
entre los doce no excepto el hombre
entonces había esta carrera que fue
organizada y que los doce primeros
formarían el zodiaco chino y entonces
se iría pues en orden de la llegada no
entonces dice que los primeros en ese el
día de la carrera el gato y el ratón que
eran en aquella época muy buenos amigos
partieron juntos para la carrera pero se
encontraron con un obstáculo en el
camino y un río
había un río y
después de ello venía el buey que muy
amablemente se ofreció para cruzar
cruzar los del otro lado y es el gato y
el ratón se subieron en la espalda del
buey y se los comió no se salvó de que
cuando iban a la en la mitad del río el
ratón empujó al gato
el gato no le gusta el agua
al agua y cuando llegó a la otra orilla
el buey el gato el ratón digo salto y
fue el primero en llegar y es por eso
que es el primer animal en el calendario
del zodiaco evidentemente el segundo es
el es el buey que no el segundo no es el
buey el segundo es el
lo tenía anotado
en el calendario chino es el año del
gato mojado
no dice que el buey efectivamente quedó
en segundo lugar y después más tarde
llegaron el tigre el conejo el dragón la
serpiente el caballo la cabra el mono el
gallo el perro y el cerdo y el gato y el
gato no está en calendario pero como
estaba más cerca de la orilla anterior
se volvió hasta fuera del tiempo
entonces sus nueve vidas ya nos dejaron
cierto bueno entonces ese era por el año
lunar chino el que comienza a que
comienza hoy y nosotros acá como de
costumbre en este castor cibernético
vamos a comenzar no sé si ustedes tienen
alguna noticia o algo inédito que les
haya atraído esta semana si a mí en un
reportaje que se hizo en varios
periódicos del mundo su versión en
internet que rinden cuenta de un
hermosísimo museo que existe a 60
kilómetros de pyongyang
donde se está realizando los juegos
olímpicos y es el museo del pene
está entre los animales entre los doce
sexo masculino exacto y es un parque y
hay fotos en distintos periódicos donde
muestran y hay esculturas de pene amigas
y en pocos días
parece que súper llamativo y súper
interesante y muy concurrido y está a 60
km nada más
de dónde se están realizando los juegos
olímpicos este año y desde cuándo existe
muchísimo si es antiquísimo y hay un
parque o sea hubo este un periodista que
hace
programas de misiones divertidas en la
televisión ya rengifo el informan que le
llama que hizo un justamente un
reportaje sobre ese lugar bueno a mí en
realidad es siguiendo con el tema de los
juegos olímpicos no siempre me sorprende
lo mismo y es cuando son los juegos de
invierno es ver la velocidad a la que
van los atletas en este por ejemplo está
esta disciplina que no la entiendo muy
bien que creo que es la luz es lo mismo
la luz
en ese carrito eso es un carrito la
diferencia entre la luz y el skelton es
que la luz lleva los pies más adelante
iba a costar boca arriba mientras que el
skeleton vas de cabeza más adelante y
vas boca abajo que ser valiente porque
eso es una veloz y 130 kilómetros por
hora
es terrible
por eso digo me llama tanto la atención
ver eso y por ejemplo en el louis
el tema me imagino que es la velocidad
porque una vez que estás abajo
cuál es la maniobra que puedes hacer
para aumentar la diversidad de esto es
lo que me escapa es la inclinación yo
digo lo que va acelerando al personaje
no
las curvas cuando te inicias la
velocidad que te empuja
antes lo inicial después tiene que ver
con la posición de aerodinámica que
pueden lograr tirados de determinada
manera los movimientos que hacen para
las curvas que evitan la fricción de la
dirección es increíble y la diferencia
también es que en la louis se están
sentados y se propulsan con las manos
ambición de propulsar con las manos y
después se tiran de espalda mientras que
el skelton y los atletas están al lado
y van corriendo y después se tiran
encima y van boca abajo
no sé cómo se llama lo que nos están
escuchando no sé si en el nombre de esos
aparatitos trineos o los trineos
trineo bala sin una cosa sí que hay
equipos de hay equipos de dos de cuatro
como sándwiches sí sí sí sí eso mandó
cuatro corriendo y hacen subir y someten
los cuatro
[Risas]
esa es otra disciplina que también es de
velocidad en estos juegos y otra cosa
que me llama la atención son por ejemplo
el equipo de hockey sobre hielo de corea
está formado por muchos quebequenses o
gente que vivió en quebec entonces eso
también me llamó la atención vi un
partido y es creo que sí
primer partido ganó corea del sur fue
una cosa en el estadio no pero pasa en
todos los países los corea del norte no
tiene tradición y entonces para estos
juegos
ha mandado anpe tan andreas como se dice
el club dado el reclutado gracias de acá
de que ve que jugadores que podían optar
por las dos nacionalidades que tenían y
que finalmente de acá tenían tal vez
menos posibilidades al formar parte del
equipo de canadá pues se fueron allá y
les va muy bien están jugando muy bien
junto con los coreanos históricamente el
gran deportista de tenis de mesa ping
pong argentino es el chino
esa es la disciplina argentina siguió
jugándose nacionales argentinos y
después fue por argentina y ganó
medallas en los panamericanos y ganó
medallas no nunca novedades en los
olímpicos pero un muy buen nivel
chino yo lo he escuchado en en
entrevistas en español con defectos en
la pronunciación pero muy argentino
desde chiquito que viene argentina y le
gustaba el ping pong y siguió su carrera
tímpano y la otra cosa es que son no son
de apellido les gens honguito porque sí
en principio corea del norte no debía
estar en los olímpicos
alves que estaba pues por esta guerra
digamos de los botones nucleares el que
lo tuviera más grande no entre eeuu y
corea del norte y finalmente pues corea
del sur y corea del norte entraron en
unas negociaciones al margen de las
discusiones con eeuu y lograron pues
formar algunos equipos y participar
sobre los olímpicos la otra cosa me da
angustia son
los rusos que participan pero no
federados así que aparece no olímpico
rusos y con atletas olímpicos entonces
parece no parece bandera aparecen los
anillos olímpicos cuando cuando cuando
participa uno de estos de estos atletas
ya rojo lo que me sorprende desde hace
un par de semanas que son dos o tres
semanas ya es que en la política
canadiense y específicamente en la
política quebequense
la oposición ha nombrado un responsable
de la identidad
así que estamos en año electoral en la
provincia de québec ese va elegir un
nuevo gobierno probablemente octubre y
pues la cuestión de la identidad está
sobre la mesa y esa idea que pensar el
hecho de que hay una persona que está en
el parlamento que es hace parte de la
oposición en esta provincia una
provincia de 8 millones de habitantes la
provincia francófona en la que habrá un
encargado de la identidad así que ese es
el próximo interesante cómo va a navegar
qué elementos va a tomar que a identidad
de línea se está hablando en un contexto
en que pues es by más y más a movimiento
de gente en todo el mundo así que ese es
como ver el siglo 19 peleándose con el
siglo 21 bueno pues habría sería
interesante ver cómo es que van
definitivamente a definir la identidad
entonces deje identidad
vamos a hablar es que no sé si se va a
lograr algún día definir la identidad
como tal
una identidad de una persona puede tener
muchas identidades eso ya se sabe vamos
con esta conquista
bueno especiales los juegos olímpicos
pasados no los anteriores los los de
verano el equipo canadiense tenía más
del 60 por ciento eran inmigrantes o
hijos de inmigrantes porque desde eso
eso es canadá está bien o sea es el
reflejo de lo que es canadá ahora cuál
será el reflejo para alguien que quiere
encasillar la identidad para que todos
tengamos una identidad uniforme
vamos a tener que liberarlo no se puede
encasillar bueno y yo por mi parte tengo
[Música]
que entonces y yo por mi parte está como
sabemos pues la san valentín
feliz san valentín feliz en américa
latina de las mismas
pero si hay también la pgje hay también
la fiesta del amor y del enamorado el 21
de septiembre es el de la amistad pero
también se celebra la sangre los
estudiantes de los estudiantes y bueno
entonces digo esto porque hay un
pueblito acá en quebec cerca de montreal
no muy lejos que se llama san valentín
san valentín y hay una señora que
trabajaba en el palacio de justicia de
montreal que ella pues era la encargada
de celebrar los matrimonios civiles en
el palacio de justicia
y bueno como ustedes saben acá los
matrimonios son más civiles que
religiosos no o sea cuando te vas a
casar aquí no no te vas forzosamente a
la iglesia sino que te vas a cómo eran
para un matrimonio
no importa qué pasa un matrimonio donde
después no hay paz 7 si mixta no no yo
tengo una paz terrible si no puede haber
mucha paz
por favor 34 intentos y 20 celos
entonces esta señora hablaba y decía
estaba viendo un reportaje por ahí que
hizo radio canadá equipos se fueron a
san valentín y ella se retiró del
palacio de justicia y está celebrando
modas ahora matrimonios en san valentín
y al parecer el día de la san valentín
hay muchísima gente que viene no sólo de
canadá pero sino de distintos lugares
del nadie ese lugar se van a ir a casar
y esta es la señora que oficia esos
matrículas el pueblo está cerca de acá
de monte
pero no tengo exactamente el de afuera
entonces en búsqueda de emociones
fuertes
ya el matrimonio es una emoción
fortísimo y la noche es muy fría con
chocolate rufo caliente
[Música]
[Risas]
aquí tengo saludo a la gente que se suma
a nuestra transmisión en maría está dice
volvemos gracias en el show contra
rincón se van a estar de saludos desde
barranquilla de colombia al pie del
cañón como siempre
javier gonzález en un cara y dice como
casi siempre pobre ticket trabajar en se
puede
aquí estoy cada semana muchos saludos a
todos en montreal y darío venegas
banegas leaño dice hola a todos siempre
me genera el mismo problema cuales no no
lo sé escuchó o trabajo
un abrazo grande no hay nada mejor que
escuchar hablar de canadá en español así
que supongo que está lejos
[Música]
mándanos un correcto
surf
mientras tanto ya que estamos con los
mensajes pues se pasemos a dar lectura a
la razón de ser de este programa que
tenemos leonora por ahí bueno es sobre
un tema de captura de caballos salvajes
en calgary escribe jose alfredo méndez
ramírez y dice esos caballos deben ser
protegidos y cuidados se pueden
se pueden estar en una silla y pueden
ser caballos de monta muy buenos tienen
mucho aguante tengo mensaje a cada de
diego muñoz por tele saludos desde
camagüey cuba me gustaba mucho escuchar
en anda cortez apuesta programación me
gustaría poder recibir información sobre
vuestro programa y algún recuerdo de
vosotros
camagüey desde camagüey nos escribe
diego muñoz por tel hay que decirle a
nuestro amigo de camagüey que bueno que
ya no estamos desde hace casi seis años
que no estamos a cinco años y medio que
estamos fuera de la onda corta no
transmitimos ya en la onda corta y que
la única forma de seguirnos es esta por
facebook
en distintas plataformas es la única
forma y si visita nuestro sitio
rc net punto o sea va a entrar ahí va a
tener toda la información y también la
gana de las américas de otras semanas
tenemos un buen archivo de nuestras
emisiones y casi todos están acompañados
con el vídeo así que sí
tengo un mensaje sobre generación x x x
la panificación de nuestros niños
anna nidia valencia dice es triste ver
como el internet es un foco pornografía
sin control hoy en día hasta los niños
tienen acceso a ese tipo de material
además que ya entran a chats con
extraños exponiéndose al peligro en el
que muchas veces les hacen peticiones
por webcam acá tenemos un pub lo que un
comentario sobre canadá no nos trata
bien eso lo dijo el presidente trompe la
semana pasada y dijo algo entonces
amenaza con un nuevo impuesto puesto
entonces el lun dice sabemos que eres un
sinvergüenza dígame usted le contesta yo
tengo a casi rupo a las cosas que nos
vienen a causa de la calabaza pomposa
el viento despejó un pelucón
si lo venía volando desde atrás se le
fue cuando dio vuelta cual no me molesta
lo más mínimo a mi teniendo que una
persona pueda usar eso pero es que para
que se lo pongan más como ser humano es
la última expresión de la vanidad
éste se come por ejemplo que ya estoy
empezando no estar bueno acá darío
banegas el año nos dice soy colombiano
[Música]
los dos perdieron poco dijiste más al
sur en el mundo real
[Risas]
y la pregunta es es burlington en
vermont en burlington ontario
lo hacemos trabajar bueno yo te beca' un
comentario de miriam rodríguez lambert
desde santiago de chile- y es con
respecto a una entrevista que yo había
hecho con una pareja de cubanos que
escribieron un libro sobre la historia
del baile y la rueda de casinos salsa
entonces ella
miriam dice respetando la opinión y la
investigación de los autores pienso que
no se le debe llamar salsa al casino o
decir salsa casino porque si bien ellos
dicen en su libro que cuando se tocaba
un mambo se bailaba mambo y que cuando
se tocaba un danzón muchacha se bailaba
danzón y cha cha cha en este caso la
salsa existe como género musical y no
como baile es cierto eso sí la salsa es
un género musical
y vamos a terminar lo que se hace en
cuba y en todo el mundo cuando se toca
lo que hoy llamamos salsa que no es más
que el son con nuevos arreglos los
bailadores realizan las vueltas de
casino o sea es una herencia popular del
baile cubano donde simplemente adaptamos
estas vueltas y las ruedas a esta música
soy de la opinión que se le debe decir
casi no no salsa casino ni salsa rueda
entonces es el comentario de miriam
rodríguez la táctica miriam tiene
conocimientos sobre el tema me
impresiona la ley yo me imagino pese
sobre sobre estos 12 esta pareja no que
de hecho estuvo aquí en montreal y que
tuve la oportunidad de hacerles la
entrevista por respecto al origen de la
salsa finalmente igual siempre hay
digamos varias ramas nunca podremos
definir exactamente de dónde viene ya lo
dijo le luthier con el tema del merengue
por ejemplo que dijo
en el merengue
en tanto post con dulce del que están
ahí en esa disquisición ahora el mambo
que menciona miriam también may ain
expresa expresión que dice que tienes el
mambo ido o que el mambo el cerebro si
nosotros te fuiste de mambo cuando te
cuando se pelearon los cables del mambo
exacto por ejemplo
cuba y en muchas ciudades las casas de
la trova o casas de la música y recuerdo
haber ido una de esas casas y preguntar
si tocaban salsa en uno de los primeros
viajes a los años 90 y los cubanos que
estaban y por menos dos me dijeron que
lo que lo que ustedes llaman salsa aquí
en cuba se llama timba
y que la salsa es más bien una expresión
que surge sobre todo por la influencia
de los latinos por ejemplo en nueva york
y la timba en argentina es el juego de
cartas las apuestas la timba y también
una una connotación peyorativa timbero
claro el tim bero es el jugador el que
es el que puede incluso gastarse el
dinero de su casa de su mujer sus hijos
y por eso tiene esa connotación también
miramos cómo va de un lugar al otro las
palabras tienen variaba varían su
significado
por ejemplo la salsa es motivo de
discusión cuando el origen y todo lo
demás no los colombianos van a decir que
la salsa es muy colombiana y tienen muy
buen hicimos grupos tenemos muchos
grupos de salsa que son excelentes
entonces pues ahí está en su salsa los
mexicanos y bueno aquí tenemos a darío
banegas años en realidad solo para
molestarme a mí y supongo ontario o sea
que no está el sur
nuevamente
bueno y gilberto martínez y saludos
canadá las américas desde nicaragua aquí
dice lo miraba a todos los viernes y
ahora bueno estamos aquí el viernes para
compartir con ustedes el contenido de
este canal las américas pero muy bien
que nos diga cómo se celebra el carnaval
en nicaragua el carnaval es el canal
entonces empieza la cuaresma exacto mía
después de mil con cenizas después de
cerca de 40 días más tarde ya es la
semana santa que entonces tengo un
comentario acá de carlos que con
respecto a la fifa y todo lo demás dice
dejen ya de engañar a las personas
haciendo los juegos con errores
si no están terminados a la perfección
no los vendan eso es engañar a las
personas ya está bien de robos sin
vergüenzas basta ya que sería la fifa
2017 y el juego es el juego computadora
es un comentario de españa entonces me
imagino que conocen bien de fútbol debe
ser el el torneo de fifa 2017
hay un juego de vídeo que se llama a
2017 por eso digo no sean probablemente
eso haya pasado no sé no tengo idea si
un juego probable muy seguramente tiene
razón leonardo aquí hay otra otro
comentario abundan ofertas de empleo en
la industria canadiense de la marihuana
dice la noticia y omar dice yo quiero
trabajar aplicando mis conocimientos del
cultivo de la mota tengo años cultivando
para mi consumo y este es uno de mis
grandes sueños saludos desde méxico yo
tengo algo que va en el mismo sentido ya
que está si este este tema sí tuvo
bastante
bastante participación de la gente
imagínate y dice manuel me gustaría
mucho trabajar para vosotros por favor
contacte conmigo para empezar lo antes
posible
justamente solo en marihuana y lo envía
jorge freddy desde san sebastián en
españa esto creo que está en país vasco
san sebastián
ya entonces él dice buenos días señor
pablo gómez varios primero que todo
feliz día de san valentín
he intentado comentar su artículo de
lunes 15 de enero pero constantemente es
una línea que señala error el comentario
no se puede guardar por favor intentarlo
de nuevo más tarde dice vivo en la
habana cuba mi nombre es josé guillermo
de la peña hernández soy ingeniero
automático y tengo 43 años no tengo
experiencia en industria de la
producción almacenamiento distribución y
venta de la marihuana tiene experiencia
no tiene pero pero dice tengo cinco años
de experiencia en el diseño de equipos
médicos
14 años de experiencia en asociación de
bases de datos y el desarrollo del
software es ante actualmente trabajo
como especialista principal del grupo de
desarrollo y soy el administrador
principal de bases de datos en empresa
eléctricas de la habana estoy interesado
en extender mi experiencia profesional
viendo la disposición de la emergente y
novedosa industria canadiense de la
marihuana dice jorge fredes nos manda
saludos busca otro ángulo el para
ofrecer centra en los comentarios
si antes un pequeño comentario aquí hay
otra persona que quiere porque tiene 15
años de experiencia fumando marihuana
entonces quiere poner la calidad se
necesita el control de calidad y debate
ahora en este momento estaba leyendo en
radio canadá civis y sobre que realmente
no está demostrado que la marihuana hace
bien medicinalmente hablando no existe
ninguna prueba científica es decir la
marihuana probablemente calme el dolor
lo cual te hace viajar posible
te distrae yo he visto no sé si
científicamente probado previstos vídeos
de personas que tienen niños con
enfermedades realmente traumáticas que
les ha pasado y les ayuda a pasar el
momento no sufre no sé si eso es
probablemente que sea eso lo que creo el
no que cura no no curar no no no han
tenido juicios aparte de calmar el dolor
por ejemplo para casos de epilepsia
también para el aceite de marihuana sino
el cigarro de marihuana calma los
ataques de sheen exactamente lo que hay
que tomar en cuenta es que las
reacciones de eeuu la política exterior
de eeuu de anti drogas que es una guerra
que ha fracasado pero que genera mucho
dinero por ejemplo en el caso de uruguay
una de las formas de depresión contra la
creación de la marihuana fue por ejemplo
que bancos estadounidenses no van a
hacer operaciones con bancos
y tengan algo que ver con la marihuana
con el comercio es otra amenaza más como
la de trump con canadá claro entonces es
de esperar entonces que esta
legalización de la marihuana también ha
generado y va a generar reacciones
negativas de parte de eeuu de eeuu ya
tiene muchísimos estados que han
legalizado no hay que olvidarse de eso
es cierto pero también no puede
imaginarse por ejemplo los estados
fronterizos la cantidad de gente que va
a venir y la cantidad de divisas que van
a venir a canadá entonces ahí hay mucho
ahí desde las agendas religiosas sin
embargo si a las agendas sin embargo por
ejemplo lo que hizo lo interesante que
hizo uruguay con respecto a la marihuana
es que está prohibidísimo vender
marihuana a la gente que no es del país
para evitar justamente que vengan de
afuera y que quieran aprovechar también
del sistema entonces quiera generar como
se hizo en países bajos el comercio de
los lugares donde uno puede ir a
consumir sin ningún problema
no lo sé en realidad no tengo idea de lo
que le dice estoy escuchando los sentado
en el sol en mi patio dice parece que la
primavera está está afuera y parece que
ese calor
mucho calor tampoco en montreal no las
temperaturas están muy agradables
félix y eso es más frío todavía
así que una por lo menos un metro se
descongeló y ahí está
cuánto tiempo aguanta sentada afuera
habrá un estado de peligro creo bueno
vamos a regresar con los mensajes de
nuestros oyentes pero antes pasemos a
los temas que queremos resaltar esta
semana y leonora tú por tu parte tú nos
dices que somos
bien habría quizá llegado a su límite
físico
es lo que dicen científicos que han
llevado a cabo un estudio y han
analizado más de 100 años de récords
establecidos por el ser humano hombre o
mujer para al exigirle más al cuerpo ir
más lejos y ellos dicen que bueno
analizaron efectos genéticos y también
medioambientales y tomaron en cuenta
como método de investigación tres
indicadores principales los récords
mundiales desde el comienzo del siglo 20
la altura de la persona hasta donde se
llegó y también la duración de vida
máxima y ellos lo que dicen es que
después de los después de 70 años de un
crecimiento de batir récords
a partir del año 1980 y pico ya la cosa
empezó como a la gran cárcel a disminuir
bueno es muy muy largo el tema porque
hay varios varios ángulos pero por
ejemplo lo que ellos dicen es que ahora
lo más difícil para el ser humano es
lograr mantenerse en esa cima que
nosotros mismos hemos
alcanzado ese va a ser el desafío no es
la esperanza de vida dicen ni el
rendimiento físico sino mantenerse y
también hay algo que me llamó la
atención en esta investigación
sobre el tema de la altura del ser
humano y que dicen que ha empezado en
promedio a disminuir en algunos lugares
y sobre todo en países africanos lo que
demuestra que algunas sociedades ya no
son capaces de proporcionar suficientes
como ellos dicen nutrientes esenciales
para sus hijos y mantenerlos saludables
lo cual esto implica un tipo de
problemas y bueno y además acá hay la
interventor son franceses investigadores
y acá en canadá está el profesor stewart
phillips que es de la universidad
mcmaster que comenta también esa
investigación y él dice que
efectivamente en deportes como el
atletismo puedes pueden que el ser
humano ya se acercó a un límite de lo
que pueden hacer sus cuerpos pero que
todavía el ser humano puede ganar nada
no según
2 que no sé si es menos de una milésima
de segundo que ya falta poco para que el
maratón se corra en dos horas a caramelo
ya eso lo hablaremos en otra ocasión y
lo que dice firman y finalmente en este
reportaje 100 se hacen la pregunta
cuando un atleta sabe que llegó al
límite de es propio y también hay otros
que proponen redefinir lo que es un
éxito en los deportes entonces hay
bastante información muy bien en jersey
nets punto sea rufo tú nos hablas del
fraude electoral en las elecciones de
honduras bueno destacó una entrevista
hecha con un documentalista y periodista
canadiense jeffrey epstein quien estado
siguiendo la evolución de la situación y
nicaragua literalmente desde el golpe de
estado contra contra presidente mel en
el año 2009 entonces esta 'lista en
tegucigalpa en este momento y lo que
destaca en esa entrevista es justamente
no solamente el fraude cometido en
honduras un fraude que es el que hay que
tomar en cuenta que hay países que han
reconocido ese fraude incluyendo canadá
cuando la propia oea ha pedido que se
hagan nuevamente si nuevamente se haga
nuevamente selección y el destacaba que
fue rechazado por la oposición claro
entonces ha habido en la parte de la
asunción presidencial totalmente
militarizada el destaca el trabajo de la
prensa en que justamente hay una prensa
es un país que es el periodismo y el
poder político tiene una relación
demasiado íntima donde hay muchos
periodistas que se hacen políticos y
esto genera conflicto de intereses que a
la larga van justamente sofocando la
libertad de prensa y también destaca en
esa entrevista que con la asunción del
presidente hernández
lo primero que se ha hecho fue la
adopción de leyes contra que
literalmente dan impunidad a políticos
que han que han participado en actos de
corrupción hoy renunció el enviado de la
oea para la lucha contra la corrupción
en honduras y también finalmente destaca
que pues se le preguntaba si qué riesgo
hay para la para la prensa no él decía
justamente que para que la prensa andar
pues habitualmente y silenciada porque
mucho de la mucha prensa mucha de la
subsistencia de la prensa depende del
financiamiento del propio gobierno así
que y una campaña de terror básico
como la que se hizo por ejemplo en
argentina con macri de sacar a empleados
públicos a diestra y siniestra a través
de unas unas campañas contra quienes han
estado contra el actual el presidente
entonces este es un documental el de una
entrevista él ha hecho varios
documentales y entonces la idea era
saber qué es lo que no vemos en los
medios de comunicación acá sobre el
fraude electoral en honduras muy bien el
leonardo gimeno tú nos hablas de pruebas
exitosas de la utilidad de la
utilización digo de nanorobots para
localizar y destruir temos tumores así
es esto de ser parte de la ficción pero
igual para que digamos los ánimos no se
despierten todavía falta un rato bien
largo para que esto sea testeado en
seres humanos pero lo que sí logró hacer
en esta investigación y que es increíble
porque realmente parece ser de la
ciencia ficción es que se logró guardar
dentro de una especie de cápsula
una cantidad x de una solución para
coagular la sangre entonces lo que hacen
es dentro de esa cápsula la atan a dos
elementos que tienen puntitas de adn que
van a ir a ubicarse donde encontraron
ese adn entonces lo que hacen es
ubicarlos cerca de donde se irriga el
tumor entonces esta cápsula va se mezcla
en el adn del lugar donde se riega el
tumor y se empieza a tirar esa solución
que le corta la irrigación sanguínea el
tumor y el tumor se muere por falta de
sangre
es realmente ciencia ficción ciencia
ficción pero lo han logrado los temores
son que uno no pueda controlar los
nanorobots y que en realidad sigan
haciendo las suyas haciendo de las suyas
y que vayan a otros
digamos por vía sangre vayan a donde se
les ocurra
lugares peligrosos el cerebro y el
corazón pero por lo pronto en estos
testigos que se hicieron en ratones y en
unos chanchos que son un poquito más
grandes que los ratones pero no son
hechos en ese tipo de animales y se
logró
que se circunscribiera el ataque de este
de este tipo de de término exacto del
terminator de los tumores entonces es
una cosa increíble porque uno pensaba
que no iba a llegar porque se habla hace
rato de que la manera de lograr que
estos tumores desaparezcan o es haciendo
un tratamiento que vaya directamente al
tumor es lo que pasaba hace 30 años 40
años atrás uno hacía quimioterapia sea
quimioterapia en general y ahora hay 30
diferentes pero igualmente la
quimioterapia y los rayos matan células
sanas entonces de esta manera lo que se
haría sería realmente ubicar el tumor
para hacer un análisis de adn para ver
dónde enviar el nanorobot que esto va de
ahí y que tire esta solución se llama
trombina para poder coagular la sangre y
así matar
el tumor desde adentro sin dañar otras
partes del cuerpo
hace poco he visto un robot que abre las
puertas ya no sé si lo viste leonard no
no no no así me impresionó hoy que se
volvió viral esto en todos lados
realmente el robot se acerca de abre la
parte de la sierra que no se la habrá
mira vos me imagino que con toda la
tecnología son capaces y es
impresionante las cosas que están
sucediendo a nivel de investigación de
estas nuevas tecnologías y que a lo
mejor ni siquiera tenemos idea de lo que
están haciendo la inteligencia
artificial tengo bueno
guillén nos dice hacen 7 grados y no hay
viento para disfrutar del sol y del aire
líneas
nelson contra el rincón dice terrible lo
del colegio miami que no hemos hablado
de debe existir mayor restricción a la
venta de armas y yo creo supongo que
hasta que el señor rever cabeza del tie
nada hay nada ni nada eso va a ser casi
casi imposible no son todos los
anteriores presidentes estados personas
tan
johnny willy navarro aquí en lima pero
reportando un gran clima en verano y en
compañía de seis granadas américa se ya
estoy listo para enviar los reportes de
la cumbre de las américas que pronto se
va a desarrollar aquí
saludos a todos en la cabina pues yo
tengo rápidamente los invito a escuchar
hubo aquí en el viernes pasado un tema
que causó la indignación en todo canadá
que fue la absolución de un hombre de un
blanco que mató a un joven indígena de
22 años y que fue absuelto justamente la
semana pasada esta tragedia ocurrió el
martes de agosto del 2016 y el fallo
pues fue el viernes de la semana pasada
el 9 en el que se absorbió a el hombre
presi esto ha causado mucha indignación
para un jurado en el opuesto de hombres
blanco la mente blanco el juez blanco
entonces esto ha causado mucha
indignación yo entrevisté aleonso
barreno que es un indígena maya
guatemalteco que enseña periodismo en la
universidad de regina en saskatchewan y
que bueno habla el habla de colonialismo
y sería interesante pues que escuche en
la entrevista en rcn punto o sea el
tiempo se nos fue como agua entre los
dedos en los controles técnicos hoy
round
blanco en la música vamos a tener joan
of arc
seguido por qué pasó por acá tenemos un
mensaje en pi la música está a cargo de
arcade fire eso lo encontraremos en el
programa grabado de radio canadá
internacional no nos podemos despedir
sin decirle adiós a todos ustedes allá
cordial saludo a todos su suerte y
gracias por su alta fidelidad a la
semana próxima